i'm surprised about this and people
don't understand why i'm surprised let
me try to explain it as best i can now
that i've had some time to process it
bill o'brien
in 2019
was made essentially the de facto gm
after the plan that was hatched by the
texans to
get nick casario from the patriots
imploded onto itself and they had no gm
and they decided after conducting a
couple of sham rooney rule interviews to
not hire a gm and just go forward so
bill o'brien was running the show bill
o'brien
was responsible for the trades that were
made labor day weekend of 2019 genevieve
and county they paid 7 million of his
salary to get a third round pick and a
couple of warm bodies in return and then
the the two first-round picks given up
to the dolphins that same day for
laramie tunzel without insisting on a
new contract for tunzel on the way in
the door and receiver kenny stills
and and then you know at a time when
everyone's saying what a mess what a
mess what a mess oh wait wait they won
the division oh and they won a playoff
game oh and they were up 24 nothing
against the chiefs in the divisional
round of the playoffs before the chiefs
do what the chiefs do and come back and
win the game and so after the season
bill o'brien's made the general manager
of the team
after the 2019 season
everything they accomplished last year
he's the gm and the head coach and he's
got a winning record and he's been to
the playoffs six times
and uh the team is is competitive pretty
much every year yeah they've got a
franchise quarterback into sean watson
right that they pay a giant boatload of
money to
before the season begins now the deandre
hopkins trade happens everyone wonders
what in the hell they were doing you and
i understand why they were doing it i
still think that having a gm in the
building who isn't the head coach gives
you that voice that can maybe talk you
out of moving on from a guy that you
just maybe don't get along with and
maybe you don't see the future there and
maybe you want to get what you can
before he he starts to have his skills
begin to diminish and he wants a whole
lot of money and you just don't want to
mess with it if you have a separate gm
you can maybe maybe talk the coach out
of it but but ownership decided to make
the coach the gm and ownership clearly
was on board with the move to trade
deandre hopkins or it wouldn't have
happened now four games into the next
season when you get the who did we piss
off schedule to start the year right
chiefs ravens at pittsburgh you lose one
game that you should have won
by a touchdown by an overturned call in
the end zone that could have gone either
way and now you fire the guy
it doesn't make sense to me i understand
there are texans fans out there were
like thank god this was overdue but
everything ownership did up until
yesterday rubber stamped everything that
bill o'brien did that's what makes it so
weird chris yeah i i i agree i mean it
did seem like okay if you're going to
empower him with all of this stuff then
let his plan kind of play out at this
point right i mean that's really where
it is
first off i mean what i want to say am i
i don't know if i'm shocked by like you
know we started off the show today it's
at 7am i don't know if i'm shocked that
he got fired you know owen 4
with the way everything like just the
the talk around the texans they haven't
looked good you know we discussed it the
look of the offense the andre hopkins
looks really good in arizona yeah all
the things you talked about laramie
tunzel jidevi on clowney i just all of
those have been hovering around billy
o'brien like i feel like people have
just been waiting to go oh they're doing
bad now we can unleash all the things he
did that were wrong you know as a gm and
used that against him and it finally
came and of course yeah they played
horrible last week against the minnesota
vikings the vikings are not a good team
and really their offense had their way
with the texans so
i guess my thought is this i put this
out on twitter last night with my
original thought and i still feel the
same
billy o'brien the gm got billy o'brien
the head coach fired that's how i feel
about it billy o'brien the head coach
i have a lot of respect for i really do
i think he's a damn good head coach as
we've seen i don't think there's you can
deny that four to six years with some of
the players and quarterbacks he had
there before desean watson i mean man he
went to the playoffs with keenum hoyer
and osweiler i mean come on now so he
can coach football
hey his his ability to be a gm that's
questionable i understand that and i
think ultimately i wonder if he even
wanted to be that's what i mean i think
all that happened yes it led to the
downfall there we know that they were
never on the same page between front
office and coaching staff there in his
whole tenure with houston i mean that's
why they made some of the switches in
the front office to begin with and of
course he came from new england and saw
whoa they kind of dominate football i'd
like to get my front office and coaching
staff on the same page as new england
and he never got it to that and yes they
you know had their issues with casario
and everything like that last year to
where they were close to getting it
there but i think ultimately that was
the downfall is that he didn't get the
front office to be able to implement a
system that then could support his
coaching and football team on the field
and that led to the demise of billy
o'brien
and then it was so weird because we just
assumed after the 2019 season they would
circle back around after nick casario
because his contract was expiring and
that was the presumption in june of 2019
well this is just delayed remember they
didn't hire the gm they're just going to
get through this season and then they'll
go get nick casar and i remember
thinking at the time you know
the patriots tend to get what they want
and if they want casario
casario is probably going to stay right
and that's how it played out so then
they just say fine we'll go forward with
bill o'brien as a gm we made it to the
round of eight we had the chiefs down 24
nothing let's let bill o'brien do what
bill o'brien wants to do you want to
trade deandre hopkins okay gm head coach
we're gonna trade deandre hopkins and i
it surely this wasn't some sort of a
setup like well let's let him just
completely tear the team apart and so we
can fire him and yeah we got what we
wanted well now the team's been torn
apart what the hell do we do next so i i
don't want to give anyone who may have
been
you know trying to plan this and and and
and let o'brien basically bring himself
down as a coach by having him do a job
he wasn't qualified to do just the whole
thing is strange the timing is odd and
this seemed to me to be potentially a
year chris where
you'd get a pass you wouldn't be fired
right during the season
because
it's a weird upside down here a lot of
these fans aren't showing up anyway so
you don't have to worry about fans being
alienated by a team that's not going
anywhere we're going to get through this
season this year
a victory is
playing 16 games that's your victory in
2020 period that's why i was so
surprised and it makes me wonder whether
other owners are gonna look at this and
say well you know what cal mcnair did it
i'm gonna do it too yeah i i agree with
you there mike i think it will kind of
embolden other owners to go all right
yeah it's a pandemic here and it's weird
or whatever but you know there's no
future here with this coach let's rip
the band-aid off and get it going right
now i i this i do think we'll will you
know maybe uh increase those chances
definitely
but you know like you i
i think you bring up a good point with
what you say
too about
you know
where they are as a team this year yeah
we know they have issues you know they
probably weren't as good as they were
last year but they have desean watson
and billy o'brien he coaches them tough
and they're battle tested and they kind
of fool you into being a little bit
better of a team than they actually are
and watson is capable of doing that and
billy o is capable of doing that as a
coach but like i think you're the other
thing you're saying like you talk about
one team that
really could have benefited from an off
season i know they all could have i get
it but when you don't know deandre
hopkins hey brandon cooks we need you to
come in here and learn the offense hey
randall cobb we need you to learn the
offense hey we got two second year
offensive linemen who are really
depending on to help our team out this
year those offseason reps and everything
so big we know development between year
one and year two they lose that hey
david johnson's on the offense this is a
complicated offense whoa he's in
probably the beginner phase of learning
all of that and everything there so
those issues are real now the one thing
i can't give him an excuse for because
he's kind of the gm is the defense and
the gm you know is the defense they they
don't have a lot of talent they have
really lost their way
and that of course is the big issue
that's kind of where i always go back to
billy o'brien the gm ultimately is what
really hurt billy o'brien the coach here
in four games that's what's amazing bill
o'brien as the gm through four games
brought down a successful coach's tenure
in four games as having that second
title not like with mike holmgren when
it wasn't working with him wearing both
hats in seattle they didn't just fire
him they brought somebody in to be the
gm yeah that's i mean that that's what
confuses me about this just hire a gm
don't fire your coach and your gm just
fire your gm right and keep your head
coach here's bill o'brien talking about
the decision that was made to let him go
on monday i think that every decision we
made
was always in the best interest of the
team we we uh we had long conversations
we put a lot of research into them um
you know there were things that that
that
that happened within the walls of an
organization that the outside public
will really never know and that's just
the way it is i mean i totally
understand that but uh
we we uh we had a lot of great
conversations that
um went into these decisions a lot of
research we had a lot of people that
helped us along the way and we made what
we believed were the best decisions for
the team that's what we always did
yeah i see
the point he's making is i'm just not
out here doing whatever i feel like
doing
we've got other people in the
organization who are on board with it
hey great idea that's right yeah let's
do this yeah hey you know there's no way
in hell they traded deandre hopkins
without making sure cal mcnair was on
board with it making the case and it's
not just bill o'brien there's another
name in all of this that that
conveniently wasn't mentioned by the
texans yesterday and he's going to still
be there the executive vp of football
operations a guy named jack easterby a
guy who doesn't have the traditional
background running a professional
football team and as a result there are
plenty of people out there who have
gotten to high positions in the more
traditional way who are taking a closer
look at jackie easterby where did he
come from what did he do we had a item
last night about an irregularity that
was on his online resume that was
changed at some point in the past
several months after i began asking
questions about it to people who hired
him for jobs at some point after he
claimed to be assistant to the director
of football operations in jacksonville
in 2004 his first nfl job that's now
been changed to he assisted with
football administration and salary cap
management so uh there's some questions
out there and see here's the thing chris
when you win this power struggle
and you're the guy who stays
you can't go hide
you you you're now front and center
and there's a dynamic in football where
certain executives position themselves
to take full credit when things go well
but when everything goes sideways
hey i'm not a football guy that's not
what i do right well you got a football
title it's kind of like bruce allen in
dc all those years you got a football
title at some point you're as
accountable as the coach
or as the gm would be if we had one and
now you know i said this yesterday and i
stand by it today jack easter b is the
dog that chased the car and caught it
now he's gonna figure out what the hell
to do with it and that's gonna be
something that we hear more and more
about there's going to be scrutiny of
what his qualifications are why he has
this job and how he morphs into a new
role without any type of interview
process that complies with the rooney
rule he's going to be the guy sitting on
top of the football mountain in houston
because
the audience of one cal mcnair
has bought it and just and he's got
every right to but everyone else is
going to look at it and say what the
hell really happened here and i think
in a very discreet roundabout way
that may be a message that bill o'brien
was kind of blinking through
as he was talking yesterday well i i
don't doubt that i mean he is kind of
one of the enigmas of the nfl jack east
derby he really is i mean
i've been around the nfl my whole life i
don't know him i know really very little
about him and i just at a base level
would sit here and go wait all right
billy o'brien is the reason jack
easterby's there in a lot of ways right
so at what point why why would jack
easter be be safe there anyways i mean
i'm just talking i'm not even trying to
i'm not trying to get personal mr easter
b i'm sure you're very good at your job
no look look hey hey no no he's in the
arena you're in the frame you're the
executive vp of football operations for
an nfl team we don't have to make any
apologies this is a big job it's an
important job
he stays o'brien goes and it's fair for
us and it's our job chris frankly to ask
questions about who is this guy how did
he get here are there irregularities in
his resume what is his experience what
are his qualifications are there other
people out there who are more qualified
to do the job and why don't they have
the job instead of him those are fair
questions to ask
you don't have to apologize now that
he's in this spot he needs to have a
thick skin and deal with it and he's got
to be ready to defend his qualifications
in his resume he definitely is and to me
just the broader thing is if you're the
houston texans and you don't want more
like billy o'brien and that's over like
jack easter b is part of that i would
think his school of thought and some of
the things he thinks about an
organization and building a team were
were somewhat synonymous with billy
o'brien and what he thought so i don't
know if this is one of those things
where you're just going all right hey
we'll finish out the year and then we'll
you know
you know tear it all down and start back
over at scratch or are they gonna like
yeah like you're saying did hear the
keys jack right the jacket in the air
the owner and like we've seen gm's do
that you and i know i mean we know of
where yeah they're they're the owners
teacher's pet for lack of a a better
phrase like you know oh hey hey mr owner
look uh mike the team's good the players
are good i did my part here's a little
green apple on your desk aren't i good
that's i'm not the problem that goes
it's very real in football oh um but
here's the difference here's the
difference
here's the difference
the gm
has true accountability as well at some
point the gm's ass is on the line and
i'm a firm believer the coach and the gm
always need to be aligned they were more
aligned than ever before in houston but
the coach in the gm always have to be on
the same page on the same track of
accountability because it sets the stage
for them to start blaming each other and
it drives coaches crazy and i've talked
to coaches about this i'm down on the
sideline busting my ass trying to coach
this team and i know up there in the
luxury suite the gm sitting next to the
owner second guessing everything i do
questioning everything i do saying how
i'm making mistakes and how am i not
getting more out of this talented team
that the gm put together the difference
here is
easter bees not
in that same yeah immediate range of
accountability so here's the question
here's the question
as bill o'brien is hatching the idea to
trade deandre hopkins what's easter bee
doing what's he saying is he saying
you're absolutely right or is he saying
i don't know i'm not a football guy so
either easter bee got it wrong with
o'brien on the merit or easter b really
don't have the chops to be doing any of
this stuff
which brings me back to the question if
he emerges from this thing
as the guy who's in charge of the
football operation and he's going to
hire everybody and he's basically the
surrogate owner and everything goes
through him what did he do to get there
how does he deserve that job over others
who have been grinding away and building
a real resume and getting real
experience and and having real football
ability it's going to piss a lot of
people off that's and and
and if that ends up being the case he's
got to be ready for people to come after
him that's the way the business works
chris we've both been around it long
enough to know people get in these jobs
and there's other people out there who
say why do you have this job you better
prove that you deserve it and if you
can't you're not going to be in that job
for very long no you're right he's going
to have to prove it and i understand the
questions i mean certainly i question it
as well i and and you know i would think
again i don't think football evaluation
is jack easterby's strong point i don't
i don't think that i don't know that but
from what i've heard so i would hope
billy o'brien wasn't asking him very
much about what i should do with the
roster or this player or whatever you
know
hopefully jack easterby has been there
put in place vice president football
operations all those type of things to
make sure the organization is running
smoothly and maybe that's where he's
good uh but if they're making letting
him get involved in football decisions
then yeah i would seriously question
that and you know i'm i'm interested
just to see where this whole thing goes
mike i really am i mean hey the houston
texans they have a prized possession at
quarterback
that is going to be a job that is going
to be a hot commodity and where does
that go because i mean this this could
go anywhere now and i think that's going
to be interesting too
and there's a dynamic at play here
because look they've given to sean
watson an incredible contract it screams
out franchise quarterback there have
been moments though and
who who who's to blame i guess bill
o'brien right but there have been
moments where desean watson has
struggled this year it's not been good
and when you don't have any blocking
yeah that's part of the problem when
they trade away your favorite target
that's part of the problem but my
concern for the texans is this
do they end up hiring a coach
who will say all the right things
about deshaun watson
and then when the coach gets there
and now it's not gonna be easy to do
from a cap standpoint
but when the coach gets there does the
coach secretly want a different
quarterback i mean you're at least
running the risk
that one of the candidates you consider
is potentially going to have another
vision at quarterback than deshawn
watson yeah you know i you can't rule
that out look at what happened when josh
mcdaniels went to denver what was the
first thing he did he ran off jay cutler
do you think that he he interviewed for
the job
with that is his as his top item as soon
as i get here i'm gonna get rid of your
franchise quarterback no
so that that they better be damn sure
that that's my point you better be damn
sure whoever you hire in houston is all
in with deshaun watson that's why
yesterday we were joking about dabo
swinney being the obvious choice because
we already know he's all in with deshaun
watson well yeah definitely i i would i
would have a hard time there there's not
you know watson has special special
qualities
i don't think there's going to be
you know many coaches that are going to
look at houston and go oh i need to
bring another guy in there i mean who
tell me who's going to come right away
no no way not right i'm just trying to
have misgivings about him right if you
have misgivings that prove themselves
out over a year or two
you know you can say the reason we
haven't had success is this quarterback
you know there's a lot of sizzle there
there's a lot of pop he can do certain
things but we're just not going to win
with him consistently you that that's
your my point is
you're running the risk you're going to
hire somebody who brings that hidden
agenda with him so you better be damn
sure that you know the interviews and
that's the thing who's setting up these
interviews who's brainstorming the
topics you better be damn sure when
you're interviewing coaches that you you
give me your plan
for using desean watson show me x's and
o's let's go show me film of desean
watson break it down and show me what he
did right what he did wrong and how you
would take him to the next level that's
what they have to be looking for and is
that is that a josh mcdaniels chris i
mean it could be it's
finally the time he makes a jump oh it
would i mean he would certainly it would
be awesome there's no doubt about that i
mean mcdonald's eric the enemy as you're
saying no doubt that's what i'm going to
say
yeah yeah oh eric b enemy is the the
first name that comes to my mind i mean
without without question i mean first
off it was an embarrassment he didn't
get a job last year i mean embarrassment
for so many reasons but then um yeah and
i mean that's the way the world's going
right though i mean i i would be shocked
i would think we're going to see an
offensive coach i would think we're
going to hear lincoln riley rumors here
we go with that you know i i think we're
going to hear all of that stuff houston
not being far from oklahoma oklahoma is
always good every year quarterbacks all
those type of things numbers numbers
numbers uh i would imagine it's going to
be somebody like that i think they're in
too deep with the desean watson and i
just think desean watson's too talented
that i agree i know i agree with you but
there's still a risk there's still a
result you're right you've got to run
the search right yeah and here's
everything too
back to jack easterby whatever power he
has accumulated he is going to want to
maintain that is a factor in who the
candidates are to be the head coach
because you don't want someone who comes
in and says get rid of this guy hey let
me tell you you want me to coach the
team i'll coach the team first order of
business is get rid of this guy yeah and
ownership may not want to get rid of
this guy remember when bill cower was
was in talks to become coach of the jets
and he ultimately didn't do it they
wouldn't get rid of mike tannebaum so he
wouldn't do it right and so so that
that's that's a factor in this as well
if you're the guy who's setting up the
interviews if you're the guy who's in
charge of the process
you potentially are an impediment to
attracting the candidates that maybe
the owner would want yeah but they don't
want to go there and and be in a
position where there's a an executive
football operations who has no
accountability who can run you out the
door if he chooses to do so there's no
doubt there's no doubt you're right i
mean if it's not the right situation
a head coach
a lot of the times these guys these
candidates yes there's only 32 of these
jobs we know that so you're a little bit
desperate to okay oh wow i got offered
one i got to take it but at the same
time there is that thought and you got
to be very careful that you don't want
to just take one and be in the wrong
situation it might be the only chance
you ever get to be the head coach and if
it goes wrong and everything's wrong and
the guy that's you know hired you and
you don't agree with the vice president
and the gm and things like that then
it's probably gonna go wrong and then
you probably won't get a head coaching
job ever again after this one fails and
that is a big part of it i think that's
even more apparent with potential head
coaches more than ever to just know that
wait is this the right support system do
i really have a chance to succeed here
and if not then i'll go back and be a
coordinator and wait for something else
instead of okay yes i got a great big
paycheck and a head coach but i just
this is rolling the dice because i'm not
in control here and i don't agree
philosophically with the higher-ups in
the organization where they want to take
this and yeah that's just tough to
succeed as a head coach and i think you
got to be very careful of uh that that
possibility
the interim head coach is romeo cornell
who becomes the oldest coach in nfl
history at the age of 73. damn he
previously coached the browns he was the
interim coach in kansas city after todd
haley was fired he did enough to become
the permanent head coach at least as
permanent as it ever gets
chris
tell me and this is a guess from your
perspective i've looked it up how many
nfl games has romeo cornell coached as a
head coach how many
well it's up it's up there because what
do you get i'm gonna say three years in
cleveland so
i'm going to say he's he's been the head
coach of like close to 58 games
83 games wow he's been an nfl
headquarters wow 83 games yeah he gets
12 more as the interim coach of the
texans and hey maybe he ends up getting
the job he's done it before i'm not a
big fan of the interim coach in part
because and this can happen later in the
year like it did when todd haley was
fired by the chiefs
what happens is the players realize oh
crap
i better get my act together i better
play hard for this guy and get him the
job because who the hell knows who
they're going to hire yeah right and
what's going to happen to me if the new
coach decides he wants this guy this guy
this guy and he doesn't want me so let's
all bust our butts to help the interim
coach keep the job and then we can go
back to sucking next year i mean that's
what happens far more often than not
there is when an interim coach ends up
getting the job hey as a football player
you don't ever want the coach to get
fired because now there's just unknowns
because now you go damn i don't you you
know like you just brought up with you
know a guy being hired and will he like
desean watson think about the guys who
aren't deshaun watson they're going damn
whoa i don't know hey honey they're
going home and i don't know if we're
going to be here next year i'm not sure
we're going to see what's going to
happen you know romeo cornell known him
for a long time of course since i was a
little boy they don't make humans any
better than romeo cornell you know he's
one of the great defensive minds we've
ever seen in the history of the sport
he'll take over seamlessly but like i
think ultimately the houston texans they
they gotta
when it comes time the season's over
they got to get fresh blood in there a
new guy that kind of re you know
reinvigorates the the city around the
team gets deshawn watson excitement
around the houston texans and i don't
think you know no disrespect to romeo
cornell just where he is at his age in
this part of his career i don't think
that's gonna do it in houston um so i
can't give to sean watson a voice do you
give to sean watson a voice in the
hiring of the next head coach i don't i
wouldn't i would not i i i would not i i
you got to make this decision about your
football team and go from there
it's it's not about oh you know
again if you start asking players
personal biases will get in desean
watson young there are some things that
he doesn't even know he doesn't know
right and to me no i would not get
involved in that conversation with
desean watson
i mean they didn't involve aaron rodgers
i figured they're not going to involve
aaron rodgers green bay they may not
involve
desean watson in houston all right
they've got the jaguars at the titans
and the packers coming up speaking of
aaron rodgers before their week eight by
we'll see if they can get a few wins and
look they're they're not done yet
there's still 12 games to play all we
know at this point is their best
possible record could be 12 and four but
of course their worst possible record
could be on 16. maybe they could have
two former clemson quarterbacks on the
roster by the time the 2021s i think
they're close to where i want to go
they're done though they i mean i i
don't see it i don't see some magical
rebound from this team not with the way
the offense is played and the defense
has been real stinky and i can't imagine
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports